hello mate my name is Ryan right and I'm
Jerry welcome to reason Society will
give you reasons to see who not a bloody
so the world's end so are you and I have
a good hang out my reason a bloody see
number one
Simon [ __ ] peg
so I'm very [ __ ] love him in this
Muslim bag normally Nick Frost is more
the high energetic you know idiot one
and then you got Simon Pegg is more
subtle and the smarter one this time it
really flipped it around and Simon Pegg
is the idiot but more of like the guy
who's literally living in the past this
time actually person zero very
over-the-top character but making very
human at the same time the character of
Gary Kane is if is a [ __ ] he's a
shyster II kind of slick he's that sort
of oily guy that you knew in high school
that you know never ever grew up it's
both funny and kind of touching I just
loved the way that Simon Pegg has great
comedic timing but then on a dime he can
switch and give him a monologue that
makes you cry like he's a really good
actor reason to see number two Nick
Frost I like how this guy was able to
tone himself down yet still be hilarious
at the same time you know well he
completely flipped the dynamic again
it's like you know he's he's not even
like his sidekick anymore they give them
a backstory where it's like Nick Frost
kind of hates this guy for most of yeah
and it's a really cool dynamic to watch
especially in light of their dynamic at
shot of the Dead and Hot Fuzz I am
concerned for Nick Frost though because
he is very overweight and I wanted to
stick around for a long time so Nick
Frost if you're watching this please I
know it's funnier when you're fat but
please lose some weight because I want
you to be around for a while you're a
funny guy
he's really funny in this but he also
they give him a lot of actual like
performance II stuff to do that when
again he's like there are monologues
that he gives where you're like wow dude
reason--i say number three the raw ting
there is writing in this film there is
write in this but something tells me
they had a script before they film this
know that the writing is excellent these
guys it's kind of intimidating because
you know I want to be a filmmaker too
and to see the consistency of men you
never fail it's just ridiculous that the
writing is solid all again I love this
setup of like it's like a 45-minute set
up for what were the real plot is gonna
do and it really is I I actually never
even saw a trailer for this oh my I
wanted to know nothing
and watching this is our case it's just
a a buddy movie in a way a coming-of-age
story and then it becomes the you know
sci-fi story that we've been waiting
that that it is and it's so cool because
it managed to actually combine both late
into the film but it made so much sense
when it actually happened if they build
it up in such a gradual way and they you
know luckily the characters and the
story at hand are already entertaining
and interesting enough and so that when
they start introducing the sci-fi
elements they're still actually kind of
surprising and fun solid comedy writing
solid drama writing late Oh boom breezy
to see number four a directing figure
right knows how to make a comedy that
has a lot of heart at the same time he
gets invested in his own characters you
really understand actors like this guy
is a genius director when it comes to
these comedy films I'm sure he could do
other genres too because if you think
about it like his films are like genre
films that also happen to have comedy in
them yeah see that grades on new movie
his action movie and his sci-fi movie
now all mashed up with comedy and his
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world was like his
and a comic book film in a way come on
they have a video game yeah exactly the
guy the guy can really mix it up all
those staples of his visual style are
there they're not quite as cranked as
they were in like Hot Fuzz but they're
all it's very much a [ __ ] right film
and what I noticed watching this is
Edgar Wright has has an impeccable sense
of timing because whether it comes from
the editing or just the direction of a
scene and then the actors to timing is
huge to their comedy and they really
have a master a mastery of it yeah I
mean this film has sci-fi thriller does
comedic elements it has dramatic
elements it has so many different
elements at play here all in those is
one big bubble and he managed to pull
the piece of art together and I'm gonna
in a strong comedic way I don't think
this is this isn't my favorite one of
the trilogy crap back it's probably
number third to me number three to me
but that doesn't make it bad at all it's
still a fantastic film it might be my
favorite man I love the [ __ ] and I think
Edgar I also directed the [ __ ] out of it
he directed the [ __ ] he did because I
was watching and I was like wow you it
really seems like you knew what every
scene and shot was gonna look
can you assembled it thusly yeah it
might be their most well constructed
film they've ever done definitely reason
to see number five that [ __ ] in Samba
bins all odds ensembles they or
something I like this you know these are
likes much older gentleman we're
watching this time around that are great
it's like it reminds me of just typical
British comedy in a way yeah Martin
Freeman who's great at all they're all
great unique characters throughout oh
yeah who's the what's the actor's name
the one who was scared of the bully Oh
Eddie Mars on yeah any Mars on loved him
too yeah let's fan they're all good well
all of them are good that's the thing is
like and again with these movies you're
always kind of looking for like Oh which
they're you know which of their buddies
is gonna make a little appearance here
or who's gonna be you know a supporting
role so here you've got Eddie Mars on
like you said you've got Paddy Considine
who is one of the Andes and Hot Fuzz
with the mustaches
Martin Freeman like you said who who had
a brief appearance at Shaun of the Dead
and Hot Fuzz I like the way how the
characters are written in such a way
word yes they are art types but at the
same time they're not stereotypical if
that is real people yeah that archetype
had made it an actual guy yeah yeah
definitely it does make sense why there
because a lot of these movies you're
watching it going what the [ __ ] are
these guys tagging along with Simon Pegg
I mean they're just idiots but in this
one it actually made sense because of
the writing and the portrayals of it you
know it's like there is that
subconscious factor of how this guy was
a leader in their youth yes so they're
gonna follow him still without even if
they're logically aware of how messed up
this is that there's something about
them that has an innate feeling to
follow even though this is a bad idea
it's like well so the other guys are
gonna be there I guess sure we'll go
reason to see number six gray and then
trilogy this is known by a couple names
of the longest of which is three I think
it's the three flavors the Cornetto
trilogy or the blood and ice cream
trilogy or just the Cornetto trilogy but
yeah it's a lot nice cream it's one of
the best trilogies I've seen yeah you
know it's and they're not exactly
they're not sequels per se of course
they managed to make three different
films that are three solid that are
three solid films at the same
time what I also think I really
appreciate what they've done here
because I feel like that's the thing
that Hollywood's kind of missing cuz
like just to plan out an example it's
like we're really all bridesmaids it's
great let's make a sequel and I was like
why why not just take those people and
make another yeah exactly and it's like
these guys got that idea and it's great
what makes you know Christopher Guest
films work it's like it's all the people
you love but doing a new story yeah
awesome you know and here it's like you
get like I said your zombie flick your
big action movie and now you get your
like funky sci-fi of invasion of the
body snatchers type of Zachary even
though it's the end to the trilogy I do
hope they make more films together I
really can make a saga that would be
great reason to see number seven the
cinematography that was one of the first
things I noticed with this film was the
cinematography I was like it has a very
old-school look to it the whole time
this vide in that opening montage where
you're going back in into the past you
know and yeah late 80s early 90s and it
really feels like it's shot to really
look and feel like you're in that time
it's shot with a certain type of grit at
the same time it definitely has like it
feels like like it was shot on a camera
like a couple decades ago or something
yeah it does look cool feels like it
feels like a real British movie it does
right and I had almost wonder if they
may have shot I didn't notice in the
credits but I they may have shot film
for this just cuz it has that sort of
feel bill puff shots you know are really
good and it's it's clear that they must
have studied some of these sci-fi flicks
you know in the process reason to see
number eight the effects they're very
good you know that's what I love about
them is that we go to these films mainly
because of the comedy genre that they
are but what they honor the other genres
so much so in Shaun of the Dead when
there were zombies kills zombie kills
yeah there's action office there's
action in this one when there's sci-fi
thriller it's science [ __ ] fiction
yeah exactly and and the effects are
done you know with a lot of love and
respect for the process that those
movies that this movie is a love letter
to you know hat there is sort of a
marriage of a lot of practical and a
little bit of CG and it's really cool
yeah the CG is you know it's a little
subtle at the same time you know they
use this in the right place they use it
they use it in the exact right places
where it's like the only CG can really
pull this off right now and it's same
time to be creepy at times to even what
I've seen he can be really creepy if it
was funny at times there were some
freaky moments you know with some of
those effects good effects no reason to
see number 9 the music again you know
Edgar Wright's movies you know he always
picks really cool music for his movies
and this one is no exception you know
yeah listen to the music the song
choices but also the score because it
does bring in that sort of heavy synth
kind of 80s sci-fi kind of score which
is really goes along with that
old-school sort of great feel definitely
though lots of cool music in here yeah
everything he said
Ryan's consensus the World's End is the
reason
genre comedies are made the World's End
is the reason seanrid comedies are made
genre comedies are some of my favorite
types of comedy films to watch I believe
all comedy should have another type of
genre round there and this and the these
filmmakers pull it off well great cast
and everything
jeurys consensus the World's End is the
reason movies of any kind are made the
World's End is the reason movies of any
kind are made I had so much fun during
this movie I felt like a kid again
because it was like you know usually you
have to hamper your expectations down
days because everything's pitched in
package but this is the first movie in
forever that I was just excited about I
didn't have to alter my excitement and
when I got in the theater I just got a
lot I was not even aware of the theater
until the credits started rolling I was
just lost in it my hero's delivering
another great movie [ __ ] can I go see it
it's awesome
all right guys he's checking out a
review for the World's End why don't you
go ahead school that comment box below
and tell us what's your favorite one out
of this awesome trilogy and then once
you're done with that once you come on
over here check out this link click it
and you'll get to see more episodes or
reasons to see cuz there are other
movies out right right and if you want
to get you know lyin right Ryan Wright
uses and we want to you know like us on
Facebook you can click the link right
here and if you want to follow us on
Twitter
you know tweet us we'll be buddies click
the link right here and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
have a new review or a video of any kind
is out subscribe click on it or your
world will end it will it's a threat
[ __ ] yeah it's right good I know
this is real empowering encouraging
stuff to get you to subscribe yeah if
you don't go if you don't subscribe we
will go on a pub crawl until we reach
your house yeah and then we will end you
yeah and before we kill you we're gonna
go the world's ending yeah that's good
yeah or something like that something we
can work on second derivative you and
yeah I find a guy named Sean we're gonna
go hey Sean at the dead yeah yeah
everybody we find a guy named Nicolas
would be like looks like you're about to
become Nicholas angel yeah would be dead
we'll find a hairy guy will be like
it'll set him on fire will be like hot
fuzz yeah
you